دول كل الغرب قاعدين واقفين ضدنا هنا في
قطاع غزه هذه مؤامره هذ حكم علينا
بالاعدام يعني اذا وقفت الوكاله عننا في
قطاع غزه حنموت و حنتجوز
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم رغم التحذيرات من النقص
الغذائي والمجاعه في قطاع غزه نحو عشر دول
من بينها الولايات المتحده وكندا
واستراليا المانيا وفرنسا واليابان تقرر
تعليق تمويلها لوكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين الاونر بعد مزاعمه اسرائيليه
بضلوع موظفين في الوكاله في عمليه طوفان
الاقصى في حين اعلنت دول منها النرويج
وسويسرا واسبانيا الاستمرار في تمويل
الانه وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
رابط بالتعليق الاول قواه الدعم السريع
تشن هجوما الاسلحه الثقيله على سلاح
المدرعات التابع للجيش السوداني والذي رد
بقصف مواقع الدعم جنوبيه الخرطوم في حين
شهدت منطقه ابييه مقتل اكثر من 50 شخصا في
نزاع قبلي والمنظمه الدوليه للهجره تقول
ان عدد النازحين بسبب الصراع الدائري في
السودان وصل الى اكثر من 10 ملايين شخص
مالي وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر تعلن الانسحاب
من المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
الاكواس والتي تضم 15 عضوا من بلدان غرب
افريقيا وقد اكدت الدول الثلاث ان
الانسحاب جاء نتيجه خضوع المنظمه لتاثير
بعض القوى الاجنبيه مجلس العلاقات
الامريكيه الاسلاميه يعلن ان الشكاوى من
التمييز والكراهيه ضد المسلمين
والفلسطينيين في الولايات المتحده زادت
بنسبه تقدر بنحو
180% وذلك خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه
عقب عمليه طوفان الاقصى والحرب على قطاع
غزه في
ملا